>> From the library of
congress in Washington DC.
>> James Sweany: On
behalf of the Researcher
and Reference Services Division,
we welcome to this talk
featuring Sarah Cowan,
who will discuss
textured abstractions,
Howardena Pindell's
Cut and Sewn Paintings.
We thank you for joining us.
I'm James Sweany, assistant
chief of the Research
and Reference Services Division.
I would like to take a
moment and express those
who made this event possible.
Particularly to May Metcalf,
reference specialist for women's
and gender studies, who
organized this event and also
to Kimberly Crawford
of the office
of Special Events
and Public Programs.
We are especially appreciative
of Ms. Cowan for coming
to the library to discuss
Howardena Pindell's paintings
with us.
The Researcher and reference
Services Division provides
reference services and
collection development
for subjects that encompass
information and all formats
for the arts, humanities,
social sciences, local history
and genealogy in the
main reading room
of the Thomas Jefferson
Building.
We ask that you please check
your phones and other devices
to assure that they do not
interrupt today's program.
Also note that this presentation
is being filmed to be available
as a web cast on the
library's website.
We will at the end
have time for questions
after the presentation,
so if you ask a question you
are giving consent to be filmed.
And now to introduce
Sarah Cowan,
Meg Metcalf of the Research and
Reference Services Division.
[ Applause ]
>>Meg Metcalf: Today I
am very excited to share
with you the work of a truly
interdisciplinary scholar,
Sarah Cowan.
Cowan, we just talked
about that.
Oh, my goodness.
Sarah is a doctoral candidate
in the History of Art Department
at the University of
California, Berkley.
Her dissertation,
"Mending Abstraction,
Howardena Pindell's
Non-Representation
of Black Feminisms,
19667 to 1986,"
examines how the artist
multimedia practice critically
inflects discourses of
advanced art and relates
to black women's
cultural traditions.
This year she is also
a pre-doctoral fellow
at the Smithsonian
American Art Museum.
After the presentation today we
will have time for questions,
so please hold those to the end.
So, without further ado, please
join me in giving a warm welcome
to our esteemed presenter,
Sarah Cowan.
[ Applause ]
>> Sarah Cowan: Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Thank you all very
much for being here.
I really love the work that I
get to do and I'm very grateful
for the opportunity to
share it with you today.
In addition to thanking you
all for taking your time
for being here, I'd like
to thank Meg Metcalf
for inviting me to speak today
and thank you to the rest
of the staff at the
Library of Congress
who make public programming
like this possible.
As Meg mentioned in
her introduction,
I'm a doctoral candidate
in the History of Arts,
which means that I spend most
of my days preparing
my dissertation,
which looks at the
first two decades
of the extraordinary currier
of US artist Howardena Pindell.
That career started
in New York in 1967
and continues to the present.
So, she's still alive
and making work.
Today I'll be presenting
material adapted from one
of the chapters of
my dissertation.
I think it's very apt that we
discuss Pindell's work today
in the context of a lecture that
honors women's history month.
Not only is she a woman who has
made a profound contribution
to her field of modern art,
but she has also
really devoted herself
to making the art
world more equitable
through her activism research
and advocacy she has shown
a light on the gender
and racial discriminations
that have persisted
in the culturally elite
sphere of contemporary art.
And I think one of her more
important insights has been
to point out that the art world,
including publicly
funded institutionism,
has been shielded from some
of the kind of social change
that the public has demanded
of other institutions,
such as our education system
or the corporate world.
And she is both expanded what
is possible within modern
and contemporary art
through her artistic practice
and she's also worked to
assure that other women,
especially other women of color,
have opportunities
to do the same.
S o, I'd like to start my
discussion today with a brief
and informal overview of
Pindell's 50 year career,
then I'll share my paper,
which looks at a small number,
it looks more closely
at a small number
of works she made
in the late 1970s.
And then there should be a few
minutes for Q and A at the end.
Excuse me.
So, Pindell was born in
Philadelphia in 1943 at a time
when that city was
fairly segregated.
She was raised an only child
in what she has called a
"Very middle class household."
Meaning for her that she
was constantly being dragged
around to various enrichment
classes, music lessons,
dance lessons, but she really
took to the visual arts
and started weekend
lessons in grade school.
So, fast forward a few years.
In 1961 she starts
as an undergraduate
at Boston University
as a fine arts major.
She encounters a lot of
racist discrimination
in the university
and in the city.
Her classes at BU
are very traditional.
The emphasis is on how
to create the illusion
of three dimensional shapes on
flat surfaces through modeling
and linear perspectives,
so concerns that had really
dominated academic art
since the renaissance
and issues like color
and composition are hardly
discussed in these courses.
So, it was really a revelation
when in 1963 she made the
short trip to Cambridge
to see an exhibition at
Harvard's Fog Art Museum,
called "Three American
Painters."
She encounters a totally
different way to think
about painting that ends
up being very impactful.
Work by Frank Stella, including
this painting was on view
and this helps to inspire
her to apply for the Master
of Fine Arts Program at Yale,
where she knows she can get a
more sort of modern education.
So, she -- excuse me --
enters the MFA program and
painting at Yale in 1965.
And the focus there is much
more on form and color.
She continues to
work figuratively,
but starts abstracting from
recognizable subject matter
in works like these,
where we can still kind
of see a relationship between
the objects or idea represented
in the titles and the
painting, but there's not
such a tight relationship,
sort of representational
relationship.
So, in 1967 Pindell
graduates and moves
to New York City
to look for a job.
After several months of a
very discouraging search,
as she tells it, she
fortuitously walks
into the lobby of the Museum
of Modern Art in Midtown
to use the restroom and she
figures while she's there she
may as well ask at
the front desk
if there are any positions
available and she ends
up getting interviewed
on the spot.
In what starts as an
assistant position
in a traveling exhibitions
department,
turns into a 12 year
long territorial career,
one of the most prestigious
institutions
of modern art in the country.
This has an enormous impact
on Pindell's life
and artistic career.
It means that she is
seeing lots of art and lots
of different kinds of art,
she's meeting tons of people,
including other artists,
and she's developing what
she's a called duel identity
as an artist and a curator.
So, she's learning how things
operate from the inside
of art institutions and
she's also experiencing them
as an artist who's trying to get
access to those institutions.
Eventually becomes the
associate curator of Prince,
an illustrated books at MOMA.
In the first decade of living
and working in New York,
Pindell drops figuration almost
entirely from her practice.
She makes artworks that
are concerned with color,
like in these spray
painted compositions.
Two shapes, the circle and the
grid appear in the majority
of her works for
an entire decade.
Can you all see the image on
the left, it seems really blown
out from here, but I can't tell.
Okay, well, it will just
have to work anyway.
So, the work on the
left is covered
in whole punch scraps or chads.
These become really
emblematic of her work.
They are collaged onto a matt
board, along with sewing thread
and powder and we see these
materials appear again
and again in her work.
She also becomes through these
works very interested in texture
in these years and I'll discuss
that in greater detail
in my paper.
So, these artistic concerns
situate Pindell in discourses
around conceptual and
feminist part practices
and also post-minimalist
art through her concern
for artistic labor and the
physical materials of art.
In 1972 Pindell is invited
to cofound the first all
women's cooperative gallery
in New York City,
which was call A.I.R.
And it is still running today.
This gives her new
opportunities to show her work
and her conversations with other
women artists emboldens her
to work with feminine
coated materials
and processes for
the first time.
But she also begins
to notice at A.I.R.,
as well as in her
fulltime job at MOMA,
that the predominantly
white feminist circles
that she was being invited
into are very reluctant to deal
with issues of racism.
And for her, as a woman of
color, it seemed really natural
that feminism as a political
project aimed at the liberation
of all women, would have to
necessarily concern itself
with the intersection
oppressions of race and gender.
But this expectation
isn't met and, in fact,
she encounters racism in
those feminist circles.
Throughout the 1970s and 80s
Pindell travels internationally
several times visiting
Africa, Japan, Europe,
India and Brazil, to name a few.
And this travel impacts her
art as she draws explicitly
from imagery and
cultural illusions gleaned
from these experience.
Then in 1979 two traumatic
events cause a rupture
in Pindell's life and career.
The first begins with a SoHo
gallery holds an exhibition
that uses a racial
slur in its title.
The show presents abstract
charcoal drawings and black
and white photographs by
a young white male artist.
And Pindell and other
artists, critics
and curators protest the
show for its provocative
and breezy use of
an anti-black slur.
While Pindell had
participated in some
of the wide spread art world
activism throughout the 1970s,
this is the first time she takes
on such a public
leadership role.
And the exhibition and protest
result in art world debate
around racism and censorship.
And in the ensuing rancor that
this causes, Pindell resigns
from her post at MOMA as she
feels more alienated than ever
from colleagues who are
defending the exhibition.
Within a couple of months
of leaving MOMA Pindell starts
teaching in the art department
at Stony Brook University
on Long Island.
She actually still
teaches there.
But at the start of her
first semester there she's
in a near fatal car accident
that leaves her physically
debilitated and with severe,
though temporary, memory loss.
Pindell's work after 1979
starts incorporating figurative
elements, such as her silhouette
and photo transfer material.
Oh, no, silhouette
photo transfer material.
So, she uses the figurative
elements taken from magazines
and post-cards as
pneumonic devices
to help restore her memory
function after this accident.
And she begins to talk about
her art as part of her attempts
to heal herself from
the accident,
as well as from the racism
and sexism she's experienced.
In 1980 she makes perhaps her
most well-known work, the video,
"Free, White and 21," which
explores the hypocrisy
of white feminists who
refuse to see racism.
And over the course of the
1980s and into the 90s,
the content of her work
becomes more overtly political
and her activism becomes
increasingly visible.
She publishes documents
and statistics that attest
to the racial and gender
biases that are rampant
in the New York art world.
She shares this work in many
formats, including it's believed
through the publications
of an anonymous woman
of color artist group
known as PESTS,
which promises to
bug the art world.
Which I love.
And essentially sets out
to remake the art world,
including her own work into an
intentionally politicized zone.
In recent years Pindell has
returned to working abstractly.
The last few years have
been really remarkable
for exposing her work to
new and larger audiences.
She currently has a
retrospective on view
at the Museum of
Contemporary Art Chicago
that has over 130 works in it.
If you have a chance to go
to Chicago in the next couple
of months, I hope you'll see it.
and within the last
year examples
of her works have been
included in major exhibitions
at the Brooklyn Museum, the Tate
Modern, a show that traveled
to the National Museum of
Women in the Arts here in DC
and there's an example of
a cut and sewn painting
in up Outliers, an
American Vanguard Arts,
the National Gallery of Arts,
so I hope you'll get
a chance to see that.
It's a little closer
than Chicago.
So, this is a very exciting,
if somewhat urgently busy time
to be thinking about
Pindell's work.
I hope this overview has given
you a little bit of a sense
of the shape of her career
if you weren't familiar
with it yet.
And I will launch
into my paper now.
Again, we should have a few
minutes at the end for Q
and A. These are
very washed out.
I apologize that you won't
actually be able to see some
of the details that
I'm describing.
You'll just have to hang
onto my words, I guess.
So, in 1976 Howardena
Pindell began making cut
and sewn paintings by
cutting strips of canvas,
sewing them together into
a large rectangular grid
and covering them with
collaged and painted materials
to form an abstract field.
Pale, pastel hues dominate
these all over compositions,
though there are specks
of more colorful color.
There are specks of color
that model their surfaces
and a closer work,
which is solicited
by these colorful irregularities
reveals a dense nubby texture.
Small pieces of paper,
which are chads produced
by a hole punch are ossified,
in gesso and acrylic paint
and countless of these
extend from the works.
These protuberant
surfaces invite the viewer
to move around the paintings.
And with different
views we catch glimpses
of the small shadows and
valleys cast by collaged chads,
the seams of canvas
strips and the sparkle
of a large quantity
of dust and glitter.
And even with the best
slides, not all of this,
like the glitter,
really translates
to digital photography.
Viewed from up close the
paintings elicit a sense
of wonderment.
Opening up questions about their
facture and the artist's labors.
How did Pindell manage to apply
this massive material fragments
to the surface of the canvas?
How much time did such an
intricate technique require?
But the more pressing
question raised by cut
and sewn paintings arises from
the viewer's tactile curiosity.
What does it feel like?
Modernist arts prohibition
against touch frustrates
direct response
to the edge of our fingertips.
Rather our experience
of the paintings shovels
between the words textural,
feel and the conventions
of viewership.
Suggesting that something
could take root in the tension
between these ways
of knowing the world.
Between 1977 and 1981 Pindell
completed six abstract cut
and sew paintings.
On average each of the
paintings took 12 months to make
and measures around 7
by 8 and a half feet.
So, they're very large.
Five of the works
hang horizontally,
evoking landscapes.
While a single example
is vertically oriented,
like portraiture.
And the artist created them
in the hours you could squeeze
out of her work week, which
-- during which, as we know,
she was working fulltime
at MOMA.
I argue that the dense
surfaces of the cut
and sew paintings mark an
understudy turning point
in Pindell's artistic career.
The cut and sew canvases
mark the culmination
of her increasing
concern for an aspect
of painting beyond
the strictly visual.
Texture, or what she has
called surface tension.
I argue that largely
inspired by her exposure
to African textiles earlier in
the 1970s, Pindell used texture
as a vehicle to enmesh
illusions to forms --
to these forms with
administrative and craft labor,
feminist aesthetics and
modernist structures,
which are all kind of part of
the vocabulary of discourses
of so called advanced
art at this moment.
With a surprising
combination of valiances,
some of which are
covertly conveyed,
she adapted abstraction
to a historically specific
and personal material culture.
The paintings made use of
the openness of abstraction,
to dogmatize the
ambiguities and contradictions
that subtend social identities,
ministering specifically
to her multiple positions
as a white collar black
woman artist and curator.
On July 24, 1973 Pindell
addressed a post-card
from Nairobi Kenya to her
friends, the art critic,
Lucy Lippard, and
artist Charles Simmons.
Quote, "I will return
forever changed,
we are so ignorant of Africa.
Kenya is full of
contradictions."
End quote.
Written on the artists
second day in Africa,
the text captures her earliest
impressions of the continent.
Over the course of
the following two
and a half decades Pindell
would publish four articles
on African art and culture and
speak on numerous occasions
about the relationship between
her work and African art.
Her extended engagement
with African art,
textiles in particular,
led to a change
in the way she approached
texture
and the canvas in her paintings.
A shift that for grounded the
pertinence of African textiles
to the aesthetics of modern art.
These specific uses of
African art intervened
in the rigorous generally
figurative protocols espoused
by proponents of the black
arts movements in these years.
Which I'll discuss in
greater detail in a moment.
Pindell and Lowry
Stoke sense an educator
at the Metropolitan Museum of
Art and now a well known curator
and art historian, spent
two months traveling Africa
in the number of 1973,
under the auspices
of MOMA's overseas
books program.
They visited Nigeria,
Senegal, Kenya,
Ghana, and the Ivory Coast.
In workshops and studios they
saw artists make pottery,
starch died cloth,
petique, Kente cloth,
as we see here, and jewelry.
While formative in the breadth
of artistic material
it introduced her to,
the visit to Africa was not
Pindell's first extended
encounter with African art.
In the fall of 1972 MOMA
hosted the exhibition,
"African Textiles
and Decorative Arts."
Guest curator by Roy Sieber,
an African a space
Indiana University.
The exhibition presented 250
examples of textiles, jewelry
and other objects
of bodily adornment
from sub-Saharan Africa.
For the four month run
of the show in New York,
Pindell visited the
exhibition several times a week,
so you can do the math.
She saw it many times.
There was a -- she saw a
panoply of objects there.
the vast majority of which
were designed to be warn,
held or applied to the body,
including, and I'm paraphrasing
from the press release, East
African bark cloth, woven cotton
and silk from Ghana and
Nigeria, body ornaments
and cosmetic accoutrements,
such as combs,
hair pins, wigs and tweezers.
The exhibition was very timely.
Since the late 1960s artists,
archivist groups in New York,
such as the Art Workers
Coalition
and the Black Emergency Cultural
Coalition had been organizing
to place pressure on the city's
public art museums to attend
to glaring inequities,
including around issues
of racial and gender inclusion.
Whether or not the exhibition
directly fulfilled the demands
of these groups, it
was well received,
with one reviewer arguing
that it presented quote,
"Evidence of a self-reliant
creative powers
of the ancestors."
End quote.
The exhibition appealed
to growing public interest
in Pan-African culture, which
had been spurred in part
by the efforts of leaders
of the black arts movement
to promote black
cultural heritage.
Although Pindell did not
subscribe to the tenants
of the black arts movement,
African textiles peaked her
appetite for African art
and motivated her
to travel to Africa.
This exposure to African art
and culture profoundly impacted
her art making practice,
with particular consequence
for the development
of the cut and some paintings.
Most markedly she never again
stretched her canvases, instead,
allowing them to hang free
like the flowing garments
from South Africa, Senegal and
Nigeria on display in the museum
and she also left many of
the edges of her paintings,
of the unstretched
paintings sort of loose.
The study of African
arts also inspired her
to incorporate a new way
of handling materials
into the production of the cut
and sewn paintings specifically.
Weaving, several
of the canvases,
including untitled number 19,
partially comprised
interwoven strips of canvas,
and you can just make this
out some evidence of this
in the horizontal
scene on the right.
Right there should
be a little bit
of green paint that
shows through.
But again, I'm not
sure how much --
oh, you can see it, okay, great.
So, Pindell fabricated
the cut and sewn paintings
through an elaborate
series of steps
that underscored her labor.
And so bear with
me I'm going to try
to explain how these were made.
Notably the paintings are not
painted in the traditional sense
of applying brush to
canvas, but fashioned
through an elaborate process of
accumulation that actually ends
up obscuring elements
of their construction.
So, although they're
woven, you can only see this
in these little glimmers.
She began by painting sheets
of thick paper in rainbow hues
and then excised
small dots from these
with a hole punch
creating those chads.
These chads set aside
for later use,
she would fabricate her canvas.
In some instances she folded six
to eight inch wide canvas strips
over and under one
another in a woven pattern,
sort of like a basket and
the intersecting vertical
and horizontal lines
formed a grid.
And there's also a
grid in the works
where she's not folding them.
So, sometimes it's just
little squares or rectangles
that they form a grid
or a partial grid.
And this is very much visible
when you're standing in front
of one of the works in person.
Pindell then hand sewed
the pieces of fabric
to form a seam ridden and
slightly irregular field
and you can see the thread in
some portions of the canvas.
And at this stage she would
apply thick layers of paint
and then extrude them
through a hole punch stencil,
so they're like these
tiny little plateaus
of encrusted paint
on the surface.
And next the delicate work
of collaging the previously
painted chads began.
So, she took those bags of chads
and she individually lodged
thousands of them into globs
of paint, layering them atop
one another, on their sides
and in the seams of canvas,
using tweezers and photo --
and dry photo matt spray.
More layers of paint, a
careful application of glitter,
sequence, sometimes also cat
hair swept from her studio
and a final dousing of
what she has called, quote,
"All kinds of cheap perfume,"
completed the paintings.
Whose finished surfaces,
although they would seem
to be really friable, are
actually pretty stable.
The basic structure of
the woven paintings,
long strips of canvas,
and interlaced
into a horizontal/vertical
relationship,
resembles Kente cloth.
The most recognizable of
African textiles, which can dull
and sense be woven on narrow
looms in Kumasi, Ghana.
And can dull herself has
remarked on this resemblance.
Though the term Kente can
be applied to a wide variety
of textiles, patterns
and techniques,
it traditionally refers to
a strip woven textile used
as festive dress
and royal regalia
by the Asante people
of Ghana and Ewe.
I'm sorry, of Ghana and Ewe
people of Ghana and Toga.
So, this cloth consists of
three to four inch wide strips
of cotton or silk sewn together
in an alternating
over/under pattern
to create textiles
of various sizes.
In her decision to interfold
portions of her canvases,
Pindell advanced a
fiber based approach
to the medium of painting.
But she did so while mostly
maintaining rectilinear format
points to the facts that
the material support of much
of modernist art is, of
course, a textile canvas.
She was aided in
seeing the residences
between African textiles
and modernist painting
by the exhibition at MOMA, where
the cloths were hung in ways
that made them immediately
visually accessible.
Which is a convention
of modern art display.
Rather than conveying their
bodily use and African context.
And, in fact, the exhibition
traveled to Los Angeles
and there some of the textiles
were draped on mannequins,
so they were displayed in a
way that emphasized their use
in African context more.
But not here at New York, in
New York where Pindell saw it.
Give Pindell's relish for
African art, it is notable
that throughout the 1970s her
paintings conveyed her interest
exclusively through
material means.
Particularly through their dense
and loose hanging textures.
This tactic contrasted with
ideologies of black art
that were being generated
at the time.
Beginning in the late 1960s,
agents of the black arts
movement, the cultural arm
of the broader nationalist
black power movement called
for art forms that would, quote,
stand for the spiritual
helpmate of the black nation.
The urgent need
for revolutionary
cultural consciousness,
required black artists
to work collectively
to supplant the images,
values and associations
of a dominant white
American culture
with capital B black culture.
African imagery, such as
the outline of the continent
against Pan-African colors in
Nelson Stevens, "Jihad Nation,"
which we see on the right,
played an important role
in these efforts at artistic
and political consolidation.
For a black artist to explicitly
evoke Africa in her work
at the beginning of the decade
of the 1970s, was to bring
or to risk bringing the
politics of black power
to the reading of her work.
In this same discourse
abstract art came
to be coded as racially white.
Poet and imminent black
arts promoter, Amiri Baraka,
for instance, argued
that, quote,
"Non-political black artists,
those who did not generate
overtly political content,
did not exist in the black world
at all, but belonged entirely
in the tradition of white art."
An abstract artist with very
few exceptions were assigned
to this category of
the non-political.
Art historian Darby English,
has noted that frequent
characterizations of abstraction
as irrelevant to black
experience, limited the range
of officially legitimated
artistic means
that were available
to black artists
and thereby established
a very exclusionary basis
for black art.
Black artists working abstractly
were admonished b y spokespeople
for the black arts movement as
lacking political sophistication
or castigated as capitulating
to their oppressor's
cultural taste.
So, this characterization
of abstraction probably
feels overly constraining
to the present day audience.
But we do well to remember
that as conceptual artist,
Charles Gaines, has
reflected, quote,
"Part of the black
experience of modernism was
that historically
it was an ideology
that helped discriminate
against minority inclusion
in the art world of the
1960s and the 1970s."
the abstract art on view
in New York's museums
and gallery was overwhelmingly
produced by white artists
and it was only thanks to the
militant activism of artists,
writers and critics that
museums began in the late 1960s
to devote significant
gallery space to artists
such as Alma Thomas,
Sam Loving and Al Lux --
Sam Gilliam and Al Loving.
So, given this context,
what was an abstract artist
with an affinity for
African culture to do?
Despite frustrations with her
reception, Pindell continued
to make paintings that
offered no apparent commentary
on black experience.
Producing unstretched
collage canvases
and later the cotton sewn works.
However, over the course of the
1970s she began increasingly
to turn to texture as a
non-figurative technique,
for conveying both a conscious
and what she has called an
unconscious ancestral connection
to Africa and its
visual art, visual arts.
This extra visual strategy
I argued allowed her
to intertwine her
ongoing development
of a modernist painting practice
and growing artistic concern
for aspects of her social
identity that did not conform
to the normative category
of abstract artist.
Which as I've indicated
by default was white
and white male subject positon.
According to Pindell, her
encounter in African textiles
with a charm and emulate
encrusted batakari,
or war tunic, spurred
her to experiment
with dense accumulative
textures.
Small works on map or made
shortly after the exhibition,
display her first efforts
at lifting collage elements off
the two dimensional surface.
Clusters of chads pile on top of
sewing thread that forms a grid.
Some of the hole punched
scraps even balance improbably
on their paper thin edges, kind
of sticking out from the board.
The accreted surface of
these works evokes though
on a smaller scale the
adherence of packets,
horns and shells
to the batakari.
And with the cut
and sewn paintings,
Pindell first applied this
laboriously achieved lifted
collage technique on a
large scale at dimensions
that would evoke both modernist
paintings and African textiles.
But it was the psychic
resonances
of the accumulative
textures in African objects,
as much as their visual affects,
that drew Pindell to them.
In African context, including
the Ghanaian culture of Akan,
which produced the batakari,
accumulations on the surface
of the objects have apotropaic
and empowering functions
for the wearer.
Pindell adapted this concept
to her own work using the term,
"Surface tension," to describe
what she understood as the,
quote, "empowering function
of her collaged paintings,
whose textural qualities offered
a non-dominating orientation
toward the viewer."
The unintuitive connection
Pindell has drawn
between texture and empowering
affects is probably best
illustrated through a negative
example that she provides.
Surface tension contrasts
with the manufactured finish
of works, such as Richard
Serra's Cor-ten steel
sculptures, whose vast surfaces,
although they are textured
by the metal's protective
weathered layer,
lack traces of the
artist's hand.
Pindell believes that
through their scale,
which is quite large, and
repudiation of human labor,
such works propose a dominate
or disempowering
orientation toward the viewer.
The artist has removed
himself in some significant way
from the surface
of his sculpture.
Surface tension, by contrast,
is capable of ensuring
viewers instant recognition
of the artwork as
a human creation,
by indirectly placing
the artist herself
on the surface of her works.
By awakening our
tactile curiosity
with their dense textures,
Pindell thought to make artworks
that did not alienate or
diminish their viewers.
As clear theorist, Eve
Kosofsky Sedgwick writes,
"The sense of touch,"
quote, "makes nonsense
out of any dualistic
understanding of agency
and passivity, because
to touch is," quote,
"also to understand other
people or natural forces
as having effectually
done so before oneself,
if only in the making
of the textured object."
End quote.
Each chad on a cut and sewn
painting indexes a squeeze
of Pindell's hand
against a hole punch,
and a subsequent meticulous
application of tweezers.
A direct textural recording
of these past moments
of creation further
communicates to the viewer
that someone was here before
us, someone left these traces.
Further, black feminist
art historians have noticed
that the tactile and haptic
have played important roles
in the cultural production of
women of the African Diaspora.
And Pindell has herself
identified surface tension
as a common feature of works
by African diasporic artists.
Huey Copeland argues that
black women have long, quote,
"turned to the haptic as a
resource for self fashioning
and for the preservation
of memories otherwise
lost to history."
End quote.
A haptic can serve at once
as a supplement to the visual
and a refuge from it,
providing a sight of personal
and communal self-fashioning.
In this light we night
understand Pindell's turn toward
texture as participating in a
black women's cultural tradition
that addresses the
denigrating terms imposed
by euro American scopic
regimes or what cultural critic,
Michelle Wallace, has called
the, quote, "Negative --
excuse me -- negative scene of
instruction out of the visual,"
which traditionally cast
black women in stereotype.
Pindell's theory of surface
tension implicated her own
bodily relationship to
the surface of her works,
in addition to her viewers.
She has remarked that the
extensive handiwork involved
in the painting's fabrication,
punching, the cutting,
stitching, helped her weather
the constant disapproval she
encountered as a black
woman artist and curator.
This disapproval
included the sense
that to the larger art world
she, quote, "Didn't exist."
The cumulative traumatic
stress of these conditions led
to experiences of what Pindell
has described as dissociation,
during which she felt,
quote, "Out of her body."
Tactile intensive work
in particular the process
of punching, of hole
punching intervened,
serving as a process the rough
which the artist could, quote,
"Connect with her body when it
no longer cohered as a result
of fractious social pressures."
Pindell's textural
engagement with the surface
of her works became, in her
estimation, a tool for, quote,
"Healing, that gave her the
energy to continue to make art
and show up at her day job."
Repetitive labor may strike
us as an unlikely strategy
for combating isolation.
The hand cramping work of hole
punching a curious practice
for bodily restoration.
Pindell's use of physically
intensive processes,
in particular her extensive
use of an instrument associated
with bureaucratic procedure,
the hole punch, placed her work
in the leading discussions
of conceptual arts
and referenced her post at
MOMA as a white collar worker.
Unlike many of the artists
who turn to an aesthetic
of administration in the
late 1960s and early 1970s,
Pindell was herself a
practicing bureaucrat.
In fact, she punched some of
her chads from manila folders
that she pilfered from MOMA.
There's also the matt boards
that we see, that is the ground
for the work on the left.
She got out of the
dumpster at MOMA.
They were cut out of mats that
were used to frame artworks.
So, Pindell's intimate knowledge
of administrative labor throws
new light on the idea expressed
by artist Sol LeWitt in
1967 and who's an example
of whose work we see here.
That under the logic of
conceptual art, quote,
"The aim of the artist would be
to give the viewer information.
He would follow his
predetermined premise
to its conclusion,
avoiding subjectivity.
Chance, taste or unconsciously
remembered forms would play no
part in the outcome."
End quote.
Pindell's premise with the
cut and sewn paintings was not
that of the cataloging
clerk, as Lewitt suggests.
By endowing administrative
materials with aesthetic intent
and more radically
the possibility
for psychic redemption or
healing, she put pressure
on a model of the
bureaucratic artistic laborer
as lacking subjectivity.
Rather she submitted
the administrative tools
of the hole punch and file
folder to a process or set
of rules of her own devising.
Perhaps as a black woman,
Pindell felt she could not
afford to forsake her claims
to a general authority, as
some conceptual artists did.
For in rarified fields
of cultural production,
black women, in the
words of Wallace, quote,
"Are systematically denied the
most visible forms of discursive
and intellectual subjectivity."
End quote.
In Pindell's paintings the
durational and physical aspects
of handiwork could function as
an erasure gesture through which
to assert, rather than
renounce her authorship.
Just want to check time.
Okay. The cut and sew
paintings do not hue closely
to a bureaucratic
aesthetic however.
Rather, they couch industrial
materials, such as paper
and string in the
craft processes
of collage, sewing and weaving.
The tension between the body
and machine captured by the cut
and sewn paintings didn't --
textures, speak to those
forms ongoing entanglements
under late capitalism.
And it does so against
the heralding
of technological innovations
that would putatively reduce
the role of labor in daily life.
Perhaps unsurprisingly,
given this skepticism
about modern labor,
Pindell's primary interlockers
as she developed the
techniques used in the cut
and sew paintings were
fellow feminist artists.
In 1972, as you'll recall,
from my introduction,
she cofounded A.I.R. Here
Pindell could share her ideas
about abstraction, situate
herself in an artistic discourse
and garner opportunities
to show her work.
Significantly for the later
development of the cut
and sewn paintings,
her formal entry
into this feminist art
circle emboldened her
to embrace feminine coded
aesthetics for the first time.
The cut and sewn paintings
are strikingly feminine.
Pindell's use of materials and
craft processes, such as sewing
and weaving, which create a
surface that resembles piecework
or a quilt, can be situated
in broader feminist efforts
to reclaim a cultural practices
historically associated
with women, which
had been disparaged
in modernist criticism.
The cut and sewn canvases
convey femininity in ways
that evoke feminine
bodily adornment.
In Carnival at Ostende,
areas of opalescent sheen,
which are reminiscent
of cartographically
masses are distributed
across a pale pink field.
I realize this probably doesn't
register, but you'll have
to take my word for it.
And in each of the hues,
sorry, each of the canvasses,
pastel hues, like peach,
pink, lavender, baby blue
or buttercream, are
the first color we see.
It's only when we get closer
that we see those
more saturated colors.
And their surfaces are collaged
with cheerfully colorful
confetti like chads and dusted
with glitter and sequence
that catch ambient light,
creating the impression as
one commentator has noted
that the paintings wink at
you as you walk by them.
Originally feminine odors
bolstered these visual cues,
as I mentioned, Pindell
spritzed the canvasses
with cheap perfume,
which carried class,
as well as gender associations.
The scent created an
atmosphere around the works,
where viewers could take them
in a kind of literal sense,
because smell entails
the incorporation
of visible particles
into the body.
Scent amplified the feminine
presents of the paintings
and activated them
as surrogate bodies.
The perfume brought
another haptic residence
to the paintings, reaching
out and touching the viewer.
The conspicuous artificiality of
the paintings glitter sequence
and perfume proposed a
femininity that is put,
self-made and exaggerat4ed.
Even though those
markers are also subdued
and this abstract composition
that muffles their
flirtation with camp.
This sidelong approach
to femininity contrasts
with the more literal searches
for viable feminists --
feminine aesthetics
undertaken by feminist artists,
such as Miriam Schapiro
in these years.
Pindell's presentation
of bedazzled surfaces also
reminds us that for her
and other women of color
artists working in the context
of 1970s feminisms, notions
of femininity were complicated
by the implicit racialization
of womanhood
by voluble white feminists,
who took their experiences
as women to be representative.
And, again, really disavowed
the idea that women of color,
the experiences of the women of
color around racism had anything
to do with what it
meant to be a woman.
With this in view,
the paintings tongue
in cheek feminine aesthetic
might signal a covert black
feminist politics, and not
only modernist criticism,
but also at accounts of
femininity that appealed
to gender nature
and thereby served
to uphold racially exclusionary
notions of womanhood.
Finally, one of the
more provocative aspects
of Pindell's approach
to feminist art was her
adamant use of modernist forms.
Such as all over
abstraction and the grid.
At the end of the 1970s Lupard
famously voiced the widespread
view that feminism was
antithetical to modernism
and her reflection that quote,
"Feminisms greatest contribution
to the future of art has
probably been precisely its lack
of contribution to modernism."
End quote.
Without an easily identifiable
and unequivocal message,
abstract art was viewed at times
as a masculinist modernist
holdover by feminist artist.
Black women artists then
were addressed by the demands
of black arts leaders
and feminists to work
in figuratively and
expressly political modes.
Artists Adrian Piper's remarks
that she made abstract work,
quote, "In the Garden
of Eden before she found
out she was a black woman," end
quote, suggests both a naivet
that these cultural
discourses imposed
on black women abstractionists
and also the sobering reality
that their decisions to
work abstractly could result
in dismissal or other
forms of artistic exile.
To conclude, the cut and sew
paintings bring together what
we've often thought of as
irreconcilable forms of labor.
The paperwork of bureaucracy,
craft procedures, the routines
of feminine bodily
adornment, and the seclusion
of modernist studio painting.
But each of these speaks
to Pindell's effortful
movement through the world.
They give us no clear,
singular or fixed sense of where
to place them or the artist.
Rather through their use of
texture and their overlaying
of the modernist grid can
take cloth and the quilt.
The cuttings from paintings
surface the tensions
that Pindell encountered
in artistic discourses
of the 1970s.
They knot and make less
comfortable supposed antinomies
of late 20th century
art, so as those posited
between African cultural
affinities,
feminist commitments
and modernist things.
Looking at them 40 years
after they were made they
ask us what possibilities
and constraints we
continue to assign to art
and how these are mapped
onto the variously
bodied people who make it.
We have a lot to learn
from their questions.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Great, thank you all so much.
So, we do have a few
minutes for questions.
I will have to repeat the
question, so just so you know
for the microphone, but yeah.
>> You said after the
accident she was doing --
using the art to
improve her memory,
help her improve her memory
or recall her memories.
>> Yeah.
>> Was that a known therapy
recommended by the doctor
or some person [inaudible]
on their own?
>> Good question.
So, the question was about after
Pindell had her car accident she
was using post cards and
other materials to sort
of restore memory
function, was that something
that doctors had recommended
or something she pioneered?
My understanding is this was
something she was grappling
through herself and
was kind of intuiting
that she could make connections
between people and places
and past events using images.
I haven't heard her talk
about being something
that was specifically
advised to her by a doctor
or someone else,
but I'm not sure.
It's really interesting
that this is --
basically she adapts
this therapeutic process,
something that she's not doing
into the context of her art
and introduces it
into the paintings.
And something I'm kind
of interested in thinking
through with the dissertation
as a whole is how actually
the abstract works are also --
she's also thinking
about these as being --
and the labor involved
in them as being sort
of therapeutic on some level.
Though that's less about
imagery and memory per se.
Yeah, right here.
>> Do you know anything about
whether relationships were
like with other black
female artists were working
at that time?
>> Yeah.
>> Because her position at MOMA
would have seemingly removed her
to a certain extent?
>> Right, great.
Excellent questions.
So, the question
was about if I --
what kinds of relationships
Pindell had
with other black women
artists at this time.
Yeah, so, it's interesting
because there other black
women artists obviously working
in New York in the 1970s
and including black women
artists working in abstraction.
She does become friends
with Beverly Buchanan.
They are in conversation.
She's good friends with Ari
Stooksoms [phonetic spelling]
who is a curator, not an artist.
She seems not to have formed
a real artistic community
with someone like Faith
Ringgold or Dindga McCannon
or other women who are in
where we at who are sort
of adapting a black arts
movement, sort of format
to their experiences
as black women
in her working figuratively and
are less interested, I think,
in the modernist inflected
work that Pindell's doing.
But, yeah, it's very --
the question of the sort
of different artistic
communities she moves
through in the 1970s is
complex, because she gets shown
in so many different
kinds of context.
Largely through feminist shows
and she's often the only woman
of color in those groups,
including in A.I.R.
for the first several years,
she was the only black woman
in that group and
she starts to feel
like she's really
being tokenized
by the feminist movement.
But it's also -- this
is also the context
in which she's getting the most
opportunities to show her work.
But, yes, absolutely she
was aware of and talking to
and thinking about the work
of other black women artists.
I think that she
was probably looking
at Betty Blayton's round
paintings and kind of interested
in exploring that more.
Thank you.
Yes, right here.
>> You didn't mention
Jackson Pollock exclusively,
but you did have an
image of Pollock in it.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'm wondering to
what extent would her work
with surface tension be
seen as an implicit critique
or [inaudible] to Pollock
or maybe even to Koenig,
who I also think of
as having a lot of --
because it's almost
like she's saying,
"You can't just spill paint
on a canvas, first you have
to sew the canvas
and then you have
to carefully elaborate
[inaudible].
I know you have to
repeat that, sorry.
>> Yeah, no, it's okay.
I'll paraphrase.
The question was about Jackson
Pollock, because I had an image
of his work up and if and how
Pindell's was maybe thinking
through the drip -- if I
can paraphrase so much.
I included that installation
view because that exhibition was
on view when Pindell started
at MOMA and she has talked
about that feeling like she
had really like been immersed
in the center of the art world,
that she was basically
being asked
to be a gopher for those shows.
It was being de-installed
when she started.
I think that compositionally
the drip paintings are one sort
of important touchstone in
thinking about how Pindell gets
to the all -- what's called --
known as "All Over Abstraction,"
that she's doing in the
cut and sewn painting.
Where there is not a sort of
pictorial center of gravity,
it's sort of an even
treatment all over.
She certainly thinking
about that legacy
and she's certainly having a
very different relationship
to her canvas than
someone like Pollock
who isn't touching the actual
canvas, for the, you know,
the majority of the process
is kind of at this remove
and above it and she's
really getting involved
in this very detailed way.
Which, of course, is
also gendered, right,
detailed work is
gendered feminine
and I think that's
important for part
of the critique she
is offering here.
Do we have time for
-- should we cut it?
Okay.
>> You can do one more.
>> Okay, Hannah.
>> Thanks, that was great.
My question was,
in your discussion
of administrative paperwork,
[inaudible] the byproducts
of administrative paperwork.
So, I was just wondering what
you think the stakes are of --
as compared to conceptualized,
that really is using
like the true administrative
form, she's using the material
and not only the material, but
the byproduct material with it.
>> Yeah, I think this comes --
I think my argument probably
comes more in to view
in the more extended --
oh, sorry, I was supposed
to repeat the question.
It was about -- the question
was about administrative labor
and specifically how the
chads are the byproduct
of administrative labor, rather
than the actual kind of form
that a lot of conceptual artists
were using in the early 1970s.
So, I think in the
context of the fuller scope
of her body this actually
comes into view more,
because she first
starts working with chads
when she is numbering them with
ink and then collaging them
onto graph paper in this
very orderly fashion.
And I think in that
instance she is actually kind
of like replicating make riffing
on making her own
kind of cataloguing.
If an illogical cataloging
process.
And, so, I'm trying to think
about how she develops
this different kind
of relationship to the chad.
I think that it sticks
around because
that was a really formative
practice and I think
that the sort of stakes and
questions are on materiality
and bureaucratic labor are
really interesting to her,
even as she continues to make
the cut and sewn painting.
But your point is well taken.
It is very kind of abstracted
from that context
in these works.
Okay. That's it, thank you
all so much for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.